elles sont une soixantaine inscrits à
cette retraite le temps d'une fin de
semaine
chacune d'entre elles a son propre
parcours stéphanie aubry elle a 37 ans
un mari deux enfants elle porte le bébé
d'un couple gay des français qu'elle ne
connaissait pas
comme c'est le cas pratiquement toutes
les mères porteuses au canada l'embryon
qu'a reçue stéphanie aubry provient d'un
ovule prélevés chez une autre femme
portant seulement si la france allait
créer trois transferts d'embryons pour
que ça fonctionne ça demande beaucoup de
patience patience car son avocat pour
faire un contrat partance pour les
rendez vous avec les fennecs n'ont
beaucoup de patience de la patience pour
ses proches aussi être mère porteuse est
devenu un projet familial
c'est pas juste neuf mois de grossesse
s'est injecté avec des hormones qui est
des fois ça fait des mauvais effet sur
notre corps ou des mauvaises affaires
avec notre humeur donc des fois la
maison a fait seinomarines aux blancs
dénoue conjoint il nous enfants qui est
qui prend 1 qui prennent chacun peut des
fois
pourquoi pourquoi alors s'imposer
pareilles épreuve pour moi c'est ça va
tellement un joueur de voir ce bébé là
dans l'hébreu
les papas donc c'est au temps du bonheur
pour au moins pouvoir ça faut redonner
un enfant pour port est une femme et
stéphanie aubry assure que sa motivation
n'est pas financière
surtout qu'au canada il est interdit
criminel même de rémunérer une mère
porteuse
elle peut se faire rembourser ses
dépenses liées à la grossesse ce qui
laisse place à beaucoup de zones grises
il ya des histoires des personnes qui
dit ok j'ai à louer une auto pour la
mère porteuse
mon avocat m'a dit probablement ces
criminels vous n'avez pas le droit vous
prêt à aller en prison il était partout
de la période de caen le maire prothèse
était enceinte que peut-être il va aller
en prison
c'est pas bon j'entends des ententes
entre hattab ses soeurs mais l'apport
des femmes porteuses tyrant en ce moment
aucun acteur dans notre agence une seule
personne a été reconnu coupable d'avoir
enfreint la loi sur la procréation
assistée adoptée en 2004
l'ia swan bugs la fondatrice de lagence
de consultation en fertilité canadienne
fertility consulting avait remboursé les
dépenses de mère porteuse et de
donneuses d'ovules sans reçus à l'appui
hawass tenter un peu des trois j'étais
coupable
j plaidé coupable dit m après avoir payé
une amende de 60 mille dollars et la
réformer ses pratiques administratives
son agence ne cesse de croître
elle compte maintenant 38 employés et
plus de 500 mères porteuses
c'est justement sa compagnie qui a
organisé cette retraite en ontario et
d'autres ailleurs au pays
c'est notre façon dit-elle d'honorer ces
femmes pour leur extraordinaire travail
et lee miracle qu'elle permette
mais pour cette sociologue ça n'a rien
d'un miracle pour moi c'est très
paradoxal dans une société hyper
libérale au nom du droit à l'enfant que
tout à coup on valorise le don des
femmes la concubine est ce vraiment
fâchée elle dénonce une logique
industrielle et commerciale que le
projet de loi risque selon elle de
pousser encore plus loin jusqu'où on va
t concise et les naissances jusqu'au
bout les instrumentaliser c'est rien de
moins qu une industrialisation
le député anthony housefather a reçu des
centaines de courriels négatifs comme
positif il ne s'attendait pas à un tel
flot de réactions
ce que moi je propose de décriminaliser
la question
du sperme de viol et de mère porteuse
parce que ça c'est la seule 1 le seul
organe humain ou le seul matériel humain
qui est criminalisé au canada moi c'est
pas moi qui va encadrer les règlements
et en effet je crois qu'il ya un grande
majorité du tout et canadiens qui
devrait dire oui je suis en faveur de
décriminalisation la ccao province de
faire des règlements
cette professeur de droit est préoccupé
on veut éviter l'exploitation des
capacités reproductives des femmes donc
la question n'est pas simple dans quelle
mesure peut-on reconnaître l'agentivité
de ces femmes là leur capacité
décisionnelle
mais en même temps on se dit oui ou
c'est peut-être lui ce qu'est est ce
qu'il ya de l'exploitation
l'exploitation du corps des femmes mais
aussi la marchandisation des enfants
lire songbird affirme que sa voix comme
celle des mères porteuses ont trop
longtemps été ignorée dans ce débat elle
assure que les femmes agissent en toute
connaissance de cause certaines
remarques des notaires c'est sûr ça
change je vais avoir plus de femmes qui
vont vouloir faire ça pour l'argent mais
il va quand même des familles qui vont
faire ça juste pour hôtels raisonnable
remboursement pour mes frais si la femme
a fait ça pour simplement l'argent c'est
que réussi six as fait à part toutes ces
tests a suit toutes ces règlements de
son contrat faire tout ce rendez-vous un
mange bien
c'est à la fin de journée lundi vers
santé
même si son rôle est pleinement assumé
les émotions reste forte
durant la retraite les mères porteuses
devait écrire leurs préoccupations sur
un bout de papier ce que souhaite
stéphanie aubry c'est que tout se passe
bien à l'accouchement
[Musique]
rémunération ou non elle compte déjà
recommencé devenir à nouveau mère
porteuse